En 1998, Trec Smith, un pilote de ligne, repère en survolant le plateau de Finnis Springs en Australie
un dessin immense sur le sol, un géoglyphe.
Un homme nu, qui tend un bâton.
Alors, géoglyphe préhistorique oublié des archéologues, oeuvre extra-terrestre ? Non, c’est tout-simplement le délire d’un artiste australien.
Si le doute a pu subsister, pas longtemps hein, les spécialistes ne s’y sont pas trompés,
c’est que cette image est fortement inspiré de représentations très communes chez les peuples préhistoriques,
un homme, nu, tenant une arme, rien de plus commun en réalité.
Pourtant, il fut une époque, où il était tout simplement inenvisageable de dessiner ça. Du moins, ça tout seul.
Bonjour à tous, bienvenue au Vortex !
Après l’alimentation, la guerre, qui sont des activités toutes aussi essentielles à la vie humaine,
il reste un domaine à explorer pour cette série révolutionnaire, celui de l’art,
en commençant avec une question toute simple :
depuis quand l'Humain se représente-t-il ?
Car si nous sommes aujourd’hui complètement familiarisés avec l’idée de se montrer au monde entier à grand renfort de selfie,
notre bouille n’a pas toujours été au centre de l’attention.
Au Paléolithique, le choix entre un modèle de mammouth et celui d’une Kim Kardashian pour décorer le nec plus ultra des grottes était vite fait, la grosse bestiole à poils longs l’emportait,
question de goût…
Alors à quand remonte les premières représentations humaines ?
Dans la grotte Chauvet, on connaît une figure anthropomorphe datée d’il y a 33 000 ans d'un couple d’humain à tête de bison.
Plus tard, à Lascaux, il y a 18 000 ans,
un homme ithyphallique, ça veut dire qu’il a le sexe en érection, est placé en position allongée avec plusieurs animaux autour de lui.
Alors, pourquoi on l’a représenté comme ça ?
On ne peut rien affirmer, mais plutôt que d’y voir un fantasme zoophile non assouvi, il s’agit peut-être juste d’un homme en train de rêver.
On se rend rapidement compte que ce qui compte dans l’art pour les périodes les plus anciennes ce sont les animaux !
Pas ou peu d’humains pendant des millénaires,
et BAM ! Lorsque l’agriculture est adoptée,
on assiste à une explosion de figures humaines et de nouveaux symboles.
En quelques millénaires on va passer de ça à ça.
Vous y voyez une régression ? C’est vrai.
Il y a moins de détails, les formes sont réduites à de simples traits, les aurochs et rhinocéros laineux ont disparus.
Mais pourquoi est-on passés, en seulement quelques millénaires, de la fresque majestueuse du règne animal au bonhomme bâton ?
Si nous sommes passés de ça à ça,
ce n’est pas parce que nous avons soudainement perdu 50 de QI
mais parce qu’au moment où nous changions de mode de production avec l’agriculture nous adoptions aussi un nouveau système de représentation, un système de symboles.
On appelle ça, l’art «post-paléolithique schématique».
Ne vous embêtez pas avec ce terme, ce qu’il faut retenir, c’est que cet art se distingue par un recours aux signes, à la schématisation,
là où l'art paléolithique représentait un bestiaire de manière « naturaliste » avec des attributs précis et des positions étudiées.
Les animaux étaient les stars des grottes,
dessinés en grand et avec un réel sens esthétique.
Le basculement dans le néolithique, c'est donc l'avènement du symbole.
Les figures représentées sont plus nombreuses et plus rapidement exécutées.
Les animaux deviennent, graphiquement plus vagues, parfois réduits à leur seul caractère de quadrupède.
Tout ça coïncide avec la présence des figures humaines, elles aussi schématisées,
mais dont les représentations deviennent centrales dans les compositions artistiques.
On a déjà dit comment avec le Néolithique, l'humain occupait une place nouvelle dans le règne animal,
celui de producteur et non plus de prédateur, ce qu’on observe dans l'art, c’est la traduction symbolique de ce nouvel esprit « révolutionnaire »,
ce n'est plus un aurochs aux pattes graciles et aux babines retroussées qui occupe le centre des tableaux,
mais un groupe d'humain qui danse et qui chasse,
l'animal n'est plus qu'un accessoire dans cette nouvelle histoire, il s'est en somme fait voler la vedette.
Bon, vous avez compris le principe,
mais ça serait assez réducteur de tout généraliser de cette manière.
Faut pas croire que les humains du Paléolithique n’avaient aucun symbole.
Il y a quelques motifs qui acquièrent une valeur de symbole, traits, ponctuations, animaux évoqués par un caractère,
comme par exemple une simple courbe pour dessiner le dos d’un mammouth.
Il y a aussi les idées d'énumération, des mains négatives, etc., etc.
Ensuite faut pas sous-estimer le fait que beaucoup d’oeuvres se sont détériorées pour les périodes les plus anciennes,
les fresques en plein air au bout d’un moment s’effacent tout simplement alors que celles des grottes se conservent mieux.
Ce qu’on peut quand même rappeler c’est que l'art des cavernes est sans doute lié à des rituels initiatiques,
il fallait ramper dans le noir sur des centaines de mètres à Rouffignac par exemple pour admirer les peintures du fond de la grotte.
Ces oeuvres sont donc investies d'un caractère exceptionnel, au moins par leur localisation, c’est à dire loin des habitations, dans des lieux teintés de surnaturel.
Ce que ne semble plus être, dans la grande majorité des cas, l’art post agriculture qui s’affiche à l’extérieur mais dont nous avons perdu les codes pour le décrypter.
L’interprétation des symboles en archéologie est d’ailleurs un jeu risqué pour ne pas dire quasi impossible.
Cette limite de la connaissance, de la reconnaissance, est d’ailleurs une porte d’entrée à toutes les théories les plus farfelues à base de culte solaire/lunaire, de déesse mère et de chamanisme.
Le fait est qu’on n’en sait rien et qu’on ne sera jamais en mesure de prouver quoi que ce soit concernant les croyances de nos ancêtres préhistoriques.
Et après tout, ces signes n’étaient peut-être pas faits pour être intelligibles aux yeux de tous.
On connaît l’exemple des Dogons qui gardent secret une partie de leurs symboles
et ne les dévoilent qu’à certains moment de la vie et à seulement certains membres de la société pendant des cérémonies rituelles.
De notre côté, en Occident, nous sommes sans cesse confrontés à des signes que nous ne comprenons pas toujours : c’est le cas des graffiti de nos villes, pratiquement illisibles pour les non-initiés.
Mais nous en faisons également l’expérience avec Internet qui a son propre langage.
Alors je vais pas m’aventurer dans une explication du code informatique et du langage Internet, c’est vraiment pas souhaitable,
heureusement j’ai la chance d’avoir des colloc qui s’y connaisse sur le sujet.
J’ai besoin de vous, parce que je suis en train de faire un épisode là où je parle des symboles, les premiers symboles que les Humains ont inventés pour communiquer,
pour représenter leurs vies… enfin, on sait pas trop justement.
Jusqu’à quel point, les symboles, c’est pratique pour les utilisateurs ?
L’arobase par exemple, c’est un vieux sigle que l’on utilisait déjà pendant la Renaissance.
Ça servait à signifier l’appartenance, genre, pour dire des pommes à 12 dollars le kilo, bah on mettait un petit @ à la place de à.
Est-ce que tu peux juste m’expliquer ce qu’est un meme ? Depuis quand ça existe ? C’est quoi ?
L’idée un peu populaire du truc, un meme, ce serait juste une image sur lequel on acolle du texte pour signifier une émotion, mais au final, le terme vient de Richard Dawkins.
On peut voir le meme juste comme un fragment d’informations.
Le meme en fait, c’est un élément de culture qui se transmet d’un individu à un autre par imitation.
Tu m’as parlé un jour de l’UNICODE.
L’UNICODE, c’est juste un standard qui a été créé pour pouvoir unifier un peu tous les texte sur Internet et sur les logiciels, en fait, à travers le monde,
pour pas qu’il n’y ait de problèmes de compatibilité entre les différents logiciels.
Par exemple, un document au Japon sera toujours lisible sur un PC en Hongrie, tu vois.
Ouais c’est fait pour être compris par tous le plus longtemps possible.
Nous, les archéologues, on se retrouve avec des signes qu’on interprète avec nos valeurs à nous mais on est sûr de rien et on arrive pas à les lire.
Moi je me demande, dans quelques siècles, tous ces symboles qu’on a sur Internet,
qui est vraiment l’endroit où on écrit et où on laisse notre histoire quoi.
Est-ce qu’on sera encore capable de le comprendre, peut-être qu’on va complètement se gourrer.
Écoutez, merci beaucoup ?
Tout comme les codes informatiques orientent les utilisateurs, l’une des fonctions de l’art symbolique préhistorique est aussi de localiser.
Entre les parois chargées de symboles et placées sur des axes de passages, les dolmens et menhirs visibles de loin, les sociétés agropastorales ont, par leur art, structuré le paysage.
Elles se sont appropriées les lieux remarquables pour graver et peindre leurs motifs de telle sorte que l’art balise l’espace !
Comprendre les symboles et les productions artistiques dans leur diversité c’est essayer de comprendre les bases de la création mythologique de la société qui les a produit.
Cette identité culturelle que nous aimerions approcher se heurte malheureusement aux limites de l’archéologie.
Les gestes, la parole, le système de pensée de nos ancêtres, tout ce qui ne laisse pas de trace, nous est confisqué.
Mises à part les scènes de chasse, nous sommes la plupart du temps devant des oeuvres pratiquement inintelligibles,
on ne peut pas savoir dans quel contexte culturel elles ont été réalisées.
Si les hommes ont peu à peu désiré se représenter c’est peut-être parce que le prestige social était devenu le principal moteur de la société.
Nous représentions des animaux car ils constituaient l’essentiel de notre imaginaire, peut-être qu’ils étaient même considérés comme des alter ego.
Dès que les humains se lancent dans la domestication, c’est que leur regard a changé, l’animal n’est plus tout à fait un sujet, il glisse vers le statut d’objet, d’outil, de richesse au service de son possesseur,
et les échanges économiques ou la notoriété prennent le pas sur la mythologie.
C’est ce qu’on observe dans l’art préhistorique.
Durant ces 3 épisodes on a vu comment l’agriculture a généré des stocks
qu’il a fallu gérer économiquement mais aussi socialement.
Résultat, cette richesse matérielle a permis à une certaine classe dirigeante d’émerger
et de faire valoir son pouvoir par l’appropriation des armes et mais aussi par le contrôle de son image.
Pour finir, je ne peux que vous conseiller de vous méfier du terme de «révolution»,
plus qu’un événement brutal et sans précédent qui ferait radicalement changer les sociétés dans une voie totalement nouvelle,
il faut plutôt y voir une accélération de mécanismes existants.
La métallurgie n’a pas inventé le commerce, elle a en revanche considérablement contribué - à ce que nous en savons - à en stimuler les réseaux.
Le Néolithique n’a pas constitué le début des représentations humaines, ou l’apparition des relations de pouvoir,
pourtant ces deux phénomènes explosent à cette période.
Les inventions techniques n’ont pas forcément eu le rôle déterminant qu’on leur donne sur les changements des sociétés.
On se focalise beaucoup là-dessus, parce qu’on vit une période de grand bouleversement technologique mais c’est probablement un biais de réflexion.
D’autant qu’en Préhistoire, on a que ça à se mettre sous la dent,
et on a vite fait de croire que parce qu’on se met à trouver du cuivre, les sociétés changent.
On pourrait aussi dire que c’est le contraire,
la métallurgie apparaît parce que la société est prête,
ou bien de manière plus raisonnable, que les deux se chevauchent.
La nouveauté découle du changement des mentalités autant qu’elle l’a fondé.
J’en ai terminé avec cette série, j’espère qu’elle vous a plu.
En tout cas, ce n’est pas fini, parce qu’on se retrouve la semaine prochaine, ici, à la même heure, sur Youtube.
Il y aura un live avec un invité surprise, un spécialiste, qui pourra répondre à toutes les questions que vous vous posez autour de ce thème.
Abonnez-vous, laissez un pouce bleu et je vous dis à la prochaine. Salut !